all right welcome everybody I'll will be
talking about styling and templating T
documents once I realized that I'll be
the last thought of the day I decided to
employ alternative more bust feed style
title to hopefully bring up some
Spirits so it's are you worried about
styling taking too much of your time in
20 minutes you w't anymore so that's the
general idea of what I will be talking
about all right so to set a little bit
of a a Dr
floor I'm imagining that you all the
viewers um you're either a Toto user or
you're curious about the new fancy Toto
ecosystem if you're using Toto then you
automatically have point two that is
you're able to create a bunch of
different types of
documents and you also haven't ventured
into styling yet because this is talk
about how to
style so imagine uh you're doing weekly
reports at work and some of the higher
ups want you to use the top
theme this might not res resonate with
you so we can pop out some of these
things so instead of weekly reports it
should be write a slideshow for
Pon higher ups to be
yourself and to design to be water to
Seal
theme but really as long as you can mix
and match ins it alliance with what is
happening in your
life so what I see and I felt this too
is St stying is incredibly daunting
because there's so much happening and
there's so many people that are so much
straighter at it than I will ever be and
you think this is taking forever and it
could take forever and I'm try what I'm
hoping that you will take away from this
thought is that it doesn't have to
be I have the opposite problem right now
is that I just spent too much time
writing slides but the same principles
still hold that to create beautiful
products you don't need a lot you can
get very far with just a little bit and
personal advice I time plot myself with
styling so whenever I do slides I set a
set aside time first to fit out the
theme and then once that's done I write
content and then I never touch the theme
unless that's little crtical
error so with little effort we can do
quite a lot and in this talk I talk
about the main three things so talk
about how just by changing the color
font and size of the different elements
in your toal output you can do quite a
lot so how do you write a theme we
already seen a couple of people talk
about this so far and it will depend on
the format you're using so if you have
some HTML documents or website you need
to use CSS maybe some JavaScript fancy
PowerPoint has a whole different way of
setting things up lat set also has a
whole different way of setting things up
so every type of input is slightly
different but the general idea is the
same and the toal website has the
documentation of where to find
everything
for the rest of the talk I will assume
you know what you want so I won't be
talking about how to
find the
perfect uh perfect font and perfect uh
Tor
palette and how to do all of that
because we simply don't have the
time so here is a a very simple well
this is the default uh HTML page for
Toro that comes up when you just start a
studio at new thing so here at the left
hand side we just have it and it looks
like how would It sped we have headers
coming up we have plane test we have tow
it prints out as well main thing is we
have like other little format up here
and on the right hand side we see how it
looks once it has been
rendered to be able to employ theming
for
HTML the only thing we have to do well
there's two things first we need to tell
the document I want to use this style
template so we said theme and then
specifying the theme you can technically
add multiple if you want and since it's
uh CSS we have the tasting stylesheet so
it will just know put them all together
and use whatever was most
recent once we have that we generate the
topond
in uh a CSS document for Toro to be able
to use this uh
properly we
need uh these tments to denote that this
is a proper scss file and different
things what should be placed roughly in
these different places but it shouldn't
quite matter where you put it but
generally you put any uh you see just
next slide right here so the way I do it
is I'm very opinionated in the way I
create my style sheets and you will see
that if you look on the top what I have
I always start by generating my taller
palette and I always name it with dollar
sign theme Dash and then the human
readable name of the tar so here I'm
creating a black a white and a teal and
a blue just because we need some
colors it doesn't have any deeper
meaning about it in general advice when
you're doing any kind of theming whether
it be for fun or for top use you don't
want too many like you can do a lot with
one two TS maybe three but once you
start adding more you get some dilution
of of
it
um another thing you might have noticed
is I have my my black and white that I'm
using but the blat isn't like the blest
blood possible I'm using like a a very
Dray but not not all the way blood and
that's simply
because uh completely pitch blood tested
on completely white background is very
straining for the eyes so just reducing
a little bit of the
contrast um is Pleasant without you
really noticing that it's a
thing you still need high enough contast
that you can actually see what's
happening but generally thr a little bit
down and the reverse is true as well so
you don't
want white white text on a dot
background like try to pinch a little
bit to together and with the
TOs this should be different there's a
million tools online of how to find
contrast to Blind friendliness so on we
have these find I have four five up here
at the top then we can use those
variables and specify these SAS variabl
so we see here we have body/
background to will see that and turn the
right elements on the documents into
that toor and there's a bunch of um
build-in s variables they're all in the
photo length so we just specify those
down and we're
using uh the theme we set at the top
sometimes there's some styling that
can't be accomplished simply by using
the SS variables that's why we use the
rule so this is just plain CSS but it's
the scss Varian so we allowed to do a
little bit of math and
manipulations so you will see in my H1
header which is the main header in the
document I'm using this dotin function
right here so I'm saying take this to
and make it 50% data so we don't have a
million head toes everywhere that might
be slightly related there's multiple TOS
in our document but we only have two
base TOs and you can get quite quite far
with this and it's generally a good idea
if you can maybe you can use this
darking and lightning things so have
some cering theme to
it changing the font is just the same we
since we're working with HTML we can use
some doal font setup to PO in the fonts
we like and then we have scss variables
just the
same to set the the variables to specify
things and to will just know what to do
make everything happen and yeah lastly
sizing it's I'm a broaden R by now you
set them up as scss variables there is
this stra idea of like the font size of
the root so like this is just it's the
size of the main text of the document
you set
that but then every most every styling
of the rest of the document is computed
as a function of this root so the H1
header normally defaults to two and a
half times the root 82 is two times and
so on and so on toad also
has uh a change in this
here we could have stop by just changing
the root
size but I decided to show as well we
can also use our variables then with a
little bit of math to create a more
coherent theme
and because there isn't a SS variable to
control the way uh the sizing of the
toad you can also manually find those
and create them a general tip I would
use is look at what other people are
doing because someone has probably run
into this before and you should steal
lot an arst to figure out oh they're
doing something we need let me take
that and so we have a document right
here and it looks really nice and to
really bring up how nice it looks I want
to show the original we worked with so
by just doing a couple of very small
modifications we seeing that our
document have a whole new
life and and I would argue that all the
Transformations we can do here can be
done by yourself in an hour maybe even
less once you get used to it it takes 10
minutes because you just take the file
change the values and you're
done so we did it we made a theme and
we're happy and we
realize oh this isn't just a onetime
thing I want to be able to use this
theme over and over then I want other
people to use it over and over then what
do I do so this is where we bring in uh
the idea of a qual
template so there this great uh tweet by
David Robinson and I'll read it for you
right now it says when you written the
same tote three times write a
function when you're giving the same
inperson advice three times write a
blood
post and I would like to uh I'll take
the honor of extending this so when
you're needing the same styling three
times write a too
template and I'll arue it takes less
time to do the T template than it is to
write an R function or to write a blood
post so creating a
template we start by traing a data
repository it isn't technically
necessary but we start by traing a a
project right here this is what it would
look like we have our index. GMD which
is what I normally use as my my base
name and we have our Styles and we have
a bunch of other things that happen when
we create a um a studio project the
first thing we do is we rename the main
document we're working with to template.
qmd that lets qu know that this is the
file that is the base of the template
that's the one that needs to be toied
over and we're done we made a template
now if this is on deop you can use the
terminal command quarter use template
the name of
the the dtop repository and this file
structure will be top it over like two
whever lcal you point it to and the
template is what's being used it will
ignore hidden files by default so it
won't topy over the r history the dit
fil all the things you normally don't
want to be toied over anyway and if
there's other things you don't want like
the um our studio project file we can
use thiso
ignore uh file added in here to then
specify with rat to say oh don't use
this don't move this file over as
well um I said that we don't technically
need a this dat
repository uh instead of detop
organization extension you can point it
to like a SI file so if it's a top
environment you might not want to put
the theme for everyone to see as long as
the user is able to point to the SIP of
this file it should all like to a SHP of
the folder everything should work out
well you can
also I showed it very simple here but
you can
use put all things in it here the
template is just whatever document you
have you could put boiler plate in there
as well so you can really put whatever
is in like the Ed template functions
is in a way just a topy paste but it
allows you to reuse the same things over
and over again all right that is all I
have I hope you trade pretty things
before I let you all know I want to
point you towards the thr documentation
so tr. it's great there if you go on
dead hop that's already like dozens and
dozens of templates for you to
use and on my personal Blood on the
third length I tra this thing called SL
trft 101 where I try to uh tell you how
to make fun things with slides and I've
done three in a year so it's do
slow thank
[Applause]
you thank you thank you we have a couple
of questions and we have time too all
right so first one what advice would you
have for those of us that are
perfectionists uh and that need to let
go and spend less time styling but you
just struggle doing so oh so brilliant
question so uh by default you're never
done styling like there's always more to
do so I would suggest like the time
blocking to do the high priority items
first and then say I have two hours or I
have four hours I time block myself to
one days of work so I say like on the
25th I style and then I won't style
anymore and then I might be sad because
I couldn't do anything everything I
needed but that that's how you have to
do
it you kind of answer the second
question which is what's your
self-impose time limit for creating a
theme yes so uh slide themes one
day
okay how do you check the accessibility
uh of your color choices as your design
gets more complex yes that's a great
question so that
is so
for like for Toler themes there is all
these great websites of how how to do
Toler contrast jetting there's a linked
on the first Blood Post in the slide
craft 101 series of how to do this um
yeah like contrast and to they have some
apps I don't remember the name but it's
a m app that will turn your whole
screen into a to blindness simulator so
you don't even need to do anything it
just makes your whole computer look
like different color
deficiencies important question what
should you prioritize in styling
well the above all we are traing
products for other people to see so the
most important thing is that the person
on the other side is able to understand
what is happening and extract
information so like Clarity above all
and
then then fun
last that's kind of
disappointing
so are there any helper packages or
other tools for this like what Sharingan
themer was to help you with the styling
or your
choices as far as I know as far as I
know no but I feel like the the SAS
variables is basically like how to make
a theme because you set four values and
it looks great if you pit great
values so I feel like really need more
theming because the variables capture
90% of what you
need so let's thank ill again and also
thank all speakers of this
session